the best way to optimize the cost per
unit mass to Mars and back is is to use
an all methane system or technically
deep-fryer methodologies so those are
the four the four elements that need to
be achieved so this so whatever Octavia
whatever a system is designed whether by
SpaceX or or anyone we think these are
the four features that need to be
addressed in order for the system to to
really achieve a low cost per cost per
ton to the surface of Mars and this is
this is a simulation of the overall
system
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what you saw there is it's really
quite close to what we will actually
build it will look almost exactly what
you saw like what you saw and so this is
not an artist's impression these that
the simulation was actually made from
the space six engineering CAD models so
this is not you know so it just well
this is what it might look like this is
what we plan to try to make it look like
so if in the video you see you've got a
sense for what the system architecture
looks like the the rocket booster in the
spaceship takeoff loads the spaceship
into orbit the rocket booster then comes
back it comes back quite quickly within
about 20 minutes and so it can actually
launch the tanker version of the
spacecraft which is essentially the same
as the as a spaceship but filling up the
unpressurized and pressurized cargo
areas with appellant tanks as they look
almost identical this this also helps
lower the development cost which
obviously will not be small and and then
the propellant tank it goes up and will
go actually it'll go up multiple times
anywhere from three to five times to
fill the tanks of the of the spaceship
in orbit and then once the spaceship is
the tanks are full Kagura has been
transferred and we reached the Mars
rendezvous timing which as messages
roughly every twenty six months that's
when the ship would depart you know over
time there would be many spaceships you
to ultimately have I think upwards of a
thousand or more spaceships waiting in
orbit and so that the Mars colonial
fleet would depart on mass they're kinda
like Battlestar Galactica you see that
thing as good show so it bit like that
and but if it actually makes sense to
load the space shifts into orbit because
you've got two years to do so and then
make frequent use of the booster and the
get really heavy reduce out of those and
then with the with the spaceship you get
less reuse because you have said well
how long is going to last for maybe
thirty years so that might be 12 to
maybe 15 flights of the spaceship at
most so you really want to maximize the
cargo of the spaceship and and and use
the booster and the tanker align so
here's the ship goes to Mars gets gets
propellant replenished and then returns
to Earth